Why does Breathing Helium Changes the Sound
of Your Voice?
The air in your lungs gets pushed up by the
relaxation of your diaphragm.
It then goes through your trachea and out
a small orifice that has two folds of skin
(vocal cords) on either side of it, in the
shape of a V.
This is called your larynx or voice box.
As the muscles that attach to your voice box
tense and relax, they create a vibration of
the cords.
As these cords vibrate, they release pulses
of air.
The tension in these muscles creates the differences
in frequency.
The higher the tension, the higher the frequency
and therefore the higher the pitch.
This frequency is measured in hertz (how many
times a second this repeats).
For example, nearly all human speech sounds
usually range from approx.
200 hertz-8,000 hertz.
Meaning the sound waves vibrate at approx.
200-8,000 times per sec.
Once out of the voice box, the air travels
into the area of your mouth that can be informally
known as your vocal tract.
As you manipulate your tongue, jaw and lips,
you can change the resonant frequencies created
by your vocal cords, allowing you to make
the many different sounds of speech.
Together, the sound we hear created by air
flowing at different frequencies and resonances,
creates our voice.
One other factor affecting pitch is the thickness
of ones vocal cords.
The thicker the folds of skin are, the deeper
the voice.
This is due to the amount of mass your chords
have that the air has to manipulate.
As you would expect then, men tend to have
much thicker folds of skin then women, ah
the soulful folds of Barry White!!
So now let’s talk about the air that’s
coming out of your lungs.
The number of molecules in a fixed volume
of gas, like the volume of air in your lungs,
does not change with the type of gas (assuming
the pressures are reasonably low).
As long as the temperature and the pressure
are the same, it does not matter whether it
is helium or air, the number of molecules
is the same.
The mass of those molecules is then measured
by atomic weight.
Atomic weight is a dimensionless physical
quantity (which is why it works so well for
a gas that does not necessarily have a given
dimension).
It is the ratio of the average mass of atoms
of an element compared to 1/12 of the mass
of an atom of carbon-12.
All that basically means is the higher the
number the heavier the gas.
Helium has an atomic weight of 4.002602.
Air which is approximately 80% Nitrogen, has
differing characteristics depending on the
environment.
(for instance if you live in Los Angeles its
about 99.27% car exhaust) 😉 Because of
this, its actual atomic weight is impossible
to precisely define.
However it is generally about seven times
heavier then helium.
So why the perceived difference in your voice
with helium?
The answer lies in how sound waves travel
through a given gas.
The more dense, or heavier, the gas, the slower
the sound wave will travel.
Helium is much lighter than air.
The speed of a sound wave through helium will
then be much higher.
So by inhaling helium and using it as the
source of the perceived sound, you are simply
increasing the speed or frequency of your
voice.
You are not changing the pitch, since your
vocal chords are vibrating at the same speed
as when you are using air.
You are also not changing the configuration
of your vocal tract.
So while the base frequency of the chords
remains the same, the frequency of the sound
heard by others is increased due to the wave
traveling through helium much faster than
through air.